لبنان الى المربع الرمادي
[موسيقى]
ضربه جديده للاغتصاد
مسوده لمجموعه العمل المالي تدرس ادراج
لبنان ضمن القائمه الرماديه
المسوده وصفت لبنان بالملتزم جزئيا فقط
بمكافحه غسل الاموال والشفافيه القانونيه
ادراج بمثابه لائحه اتهام ضد لبنان
قرار سيغلق ابواب التمويل الدولي مستقبلا
يقيد الاستثمارات والمعاملات المصرفيه
المساعي للوصول الى اتفاق مع الصندوق
الدولي لن تنجح قريبا
[موسيقى]
ارتفاع فاحش للتكاليف المعيشيه
اقتصاد
سيسير بوتيره قد تكون الابطا عالميا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات